It might seem strange, but
we should not solve problems like
the last one from left to right.
There's a set of rules we
call the order of operations
to help us with complicated
problems that have lots of terms.
This should definitely
go in your notebook.
The order of operations tells us how
to solve problems in this order.
First perform operations inside grouping
symbols, such as parentheses or
brackets.
As a note there is an implied
grouping symbol for the numerator and
denominator of a fraction.
You need to simplify the numerator and
denominator separately
before you do the division.
Second, simplify exponents.
Third, perform multiplication and
division from left to right.
Fourth, perform addition and
subtraction from left to right.
Getting back to the problem Vanessa and
Pablo worked on, the reason that Vanessa
was correct was because she
multiplied first and then subtracted,
subtracted first and then multiplied,
or worked from left to right.
Please select the correct answer.